vous avez signé cette tribune vous êtes
les nouveaux frondeurs
alors qu'est-ce qu'elle dit c'est le
tribune finalement elle part de
situation que nous rencontrons
quotidiennement dans nos permanences
pour essayer de travailler ensemble à
des propositions
positions qui ont été
évoqué à l'instant par daikoïd permettre
justement à ces personnes qui
travaillent d'accéder à un certain
nombre de droits et c'est bien cela que
dit la tribune et moi je me réjouis
qu'on puisse ainsi partir des
problématiques qu'on rencontre
quotidiennement dans nos permanences
pour travailler ensemble à un certain
nombre de solutions
mais ce que quand même le fait que ça
soit signé par des gens de gauche vous
envoyez un signal à Gérald darmenin qui
pense que pour avoir une majorité pour
voter ce texte soit voir les voies d'air
et donc faut ne pas avoir cette
régulation et son papier dans le texte
et là vous dites en fait
on a une majorité alternative avec la
gauche pour pouvoir voter ce texte
mais vous savez le texte tel qu'il est
tel qu'il est proposé aujourd'hui
contient son article 3 pardon un certain
nombre de propositions justement autour
de la régularisation par le travail
alors vous avez raison on a beaucoup
entendu d'autres types de propositions
mais on revenons-en au texte revenons-en
à la philosophie initiale qui est un
texte équilibré pour améliorer notre
système d'accueil et être plus ferme
envers ceux qui n'ont pas vocation
rester sur le territoire alors Olivier
Véran ce matin dit cap pas de problème
dans la majorité qu'on est tous derrière
le volet social vous êtes rassuré
mais c'est bien c'est bien ça
l'équilibre du texte c'est à la fois
permettre à ceux qui ont vocation à
s'intégrer dans notre pays parce qu'ils
ont démontré leur capacité à s'intégrer
notamment par le travail de pouvoir
rester sur le territoire et en même
temps de renforcer un certain nombre de
dispositifs actuels dans un système qui
ne fonctionne pas pour être plus ferme
envers celles et ceux qui n'ont pas
vocation à rester sur notre territoire
alors mogatel vous êtes sur le fond sur
la forme vous avez sous bien que de
signer avec des gens de la nuque fallait
pas les insoumis on le rappelle c'est un
signal politique qui est très fort il
paraît qu'Emmanuel Macron ne la guerre
appréciée d'autres voies dans la
majorité disent que vous êtes trop naïf
parce qu'en fait vous espérez que les
gens de gauche au final signent le
projet de loi mais qui ne le feront pas
et que donc vous mettez juste un peu de
bazar dans la majorité sans être sûr
d'avoir des embauches qui au final vont
signer le projet de loi qu'est-ce que
vous leur répondez
alors d'abord je voudrais rappeler que
cette initiative elle émane de Pascal
Brice le président de la Fédération des
acteurs de la solidarité qui a contacté
un certain nombre d'entre nous qui
avaient vraiment envie d'avancer sur
cette question sur la régularisation par
le travail moi j'ai rencontré des gens
qui étaient sincères dans leur
engagement donc bientôt il y aura un
débat parlementaire sur cette question
et je ne doute pas qu'on puisse arriver
avec toutes celles et ceux qui sont
sincères dans leur démarche à faire
avancer les droits pour pour celles et
ceux qui aujourd'hui travaillent dans
les métiers essentiels dont nous avons
besoin et qui aujourd'hui n'accepte pas
à l'ensemble de leurs